Hello, the internet, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
And in this very special video
we've been set a challenge by YouTube.
All those memes you get on the internet.
Well, we thought we'd
try and recreate those
with our own epic slow motion twist.
Bloody hell.
Oh no.
How is it, delicious?
Actually really good, yeah.
I wanna get it swished,
like I don't want it to be like clunk in.
I want it just be like
nothing but net to get in.
So if it's like literally,
like hits the thing
and bounces out, forget it.
Casual flick.
There we go.
You did pretty well at
just not reacting at all.
Look.
You're like.
Did not maintain my cool.
The whole point is deal with
it, I didn't deal with it.
I wanna spit on you.
Yeah, sure.
I've still got water in
my ear hole from that.
Next up we're gonna do come at me bro.
And I think we're gonna
fire up the wind machine
and have some wind
rippling through our hair,
and stuff hitting us in the face.
Absolutely took one in the lip there.
I'll tell you.
What was it?
I can not wait to see the footage of that.
Someone chucked a cake
at my lip or something.
It's a bloody bouncy ball.
It hit me straight in the lip.
Look at my face, I'm like, ah,
I was trying to concentrate
and be like come at me, and
I'm being hit by bouncy ball.
How can we ruin this really
nicely laid out table?
We could do the table cloth whip.
Yeah, dive through it head first.
Dive through head first, get
some good slide action on it.
Or just flip the entire thing.
Just flip the whole thing.
Up into the air.
Good grief.
That is a mess.
You really didn't like that Champagne.
Oh my.
That's mental.
Everything just stayed the same.
Look at that, it's raining cups.
That is cool.
That is one of the biggest
messes we've ever made.
Your face.
Some stuffs still there.
I did not like that.
Now it just looks like
you're angry in the rain.
So for this setup we have
two lovely crash mats,
two spring boards.
Let me have a look.
And a vat of balls.
A vat, good word.
So these are just gonna
go absolutely everywhere.
Dan, can we just get you
fondling the balls
again, please, excellent.
Can we just quickly talk
about something for a second?
This is your crash mat that
you're gonna walk along.
Lovely and-
Let me just, hang on,
demonstrate this.
Look at this one.
It's like a pile of bricks
wrapped in blue plastic.
Dammit!
That was awful.
Oh my god!
I definitely felt some connection.
Yeah, we don't know
what I hit though.
On my hand.
I think we did hit hands.
Yeah.
Look at my-
Incoming high five.
I'll count it, I'll count that.
There was some finger connection.
Yeah .
It looks like I'm just
going up for an absolute .
You're coming through a wall.
Imagine something hitting my face.
It looks majestic.
Your sleeve was over your face.
I literally landed on a
cushion of balls there.
We make attractive faces
when we hit the ground.
I know yeah.
Thanks for watching that video.
You can find all the gifs from
this video over there by Dan.
Oh yeah, sorry, here.
Meant to do that, so.